foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
is that Tony Michaels podcast real and
raw political and social commentary the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not Liberty you [__] eating
[__] ah the smell of freedom of speech
this is the Tony Michaels podcast and
this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
rushland ball is dead
still official
oh I see Rush Limbaugh is trending on
Twitter
so
and you know just yeah I think it was
yesterday we were talking about people
referring to me
people referring to me as the Rush
Limbaugh of the left
I think it's what people have said
Rachel bidikoffer has said it other
people have said it
that I'm the rushland ball to left and I
embrace it so much so that what you
should do is you should tweet that [__]
that's right you should go tweet it
because Russian ball is trending right
now let the world know
Rush Limbaugh the right is dead but the
rushland ball of the left
is Alive and Kicking [__]
and he will be for a long long time as
long as I have the power over this
microphone
you know who doesn't have power
over a microphone
that's about to get dropped
on a [__] in Georgia is Trump
now the guy goes on his stupid fraud
social and claims he's been exonerated
because his name is not in the report
that was released or the part of the
report that was released your name's
redacted you dumb [__]
like oh my God indictments are imminent
here
the grand jury has requested and
suggested that there be charges brought
for perjury uh in the matter of the
testimony that was given so we're going
to find out
who definitely purged themselves in the
testimony we know they fought this tooth
and nail
and the only reason why they fought at
tooth and nail down a jury for this for
the grand jury to give their testimony
is because there were crimes
it's not [__] rocket surgery
you [__] boneheads the reason why
they didn't want to go testify is
because it was going to put the mango
Mussolini Jesus
in a tough position where he could be
indicted on crimes and the people around
him who were trying to help him steal
our election and [__] on our
Constitution and force election
officials in Georgia to do that for him
the people around him are also going to
be indicted and so they went live for
him and they're going to get indicted
for that too my guess is is that
um Grandpa farty mcsharty not to be
confused with Grandpa Poopypants now
there is Grandpa Poopypants which is the
Cheeto dust cumin honor the former guy
Donald Trump
but Grandpa farty mcsharty is Rudy
Giuliani or Rudy kaluti depending on you
know what situation you're actually
injecting that scum back in now if you
remember Rudy Giuliani was going around
to all these state legislators right
he was going around to all these state
legislators to try to get them to submit
fraudulent electors
and overturn the electors the electors
in the state to send Donald Trump
electors to Washington so Mike Pence
could crown Donald Trump King this is
not [__] hard to understand if you
watch just a little bit of a sliver of
the January 6 select committee you would
understand especially if you watch Rusty
Bowers who is the Republican Speaker of
the House in
Arizona at the time they were trying to
pressure him into just just
spreading lies and overturning the
election overturning the will of the
people in Arizona like oh no we got
evidence I mean
kind of sort of maybe should it I mean
it's possible we don't have it with us
we don't have we don't I mean it's not
really evidence it's more like hearsay I
mean it's lies but you should overturn
the people's vote in Arizona because of
it
he was going around to state legislators
and testifying in front of state
legislators that were already going to
give Donald Trump the electors he came
to the state of Missouri
the state of Missouri he came and
testified
amount State electors when they were
already the state electors in Missouri
under the Constitution were going to go
that that state constitution we talked
about this the other day a lot of
[__] idiots all these boneheads don't
even understand that the states have
constitutions under the state
constitution in Missouri all the
electors are going to go to Donald Trump
anyways
there was no chance for any electors in
the state of Missouri to go to Joe Biden
why would Rudy Giuliani come to Missouri
they were trying to drum up support for
fraud that's what they were trying to do
and the reason why they were trying to
drum it up it's not hard to understand
when you're trying to [__] convince
people of something that's a blatant
outright obvious lie is to get more and
more people to repeat that line
especially people in power especially
people in power that can say well we had
we had an official hearing on it and
there were all kinds of discrepancies in
the boot and blah blah blah yakety
smackity right just lie after lie after
lie I mean their Republicans are really
[__] good at it
I mean they're really [__] Shameless
at lying
that's why I mean I say George Santos is
not an outlier he is a republican it's
pretty simple to understand why he does
what he does he's a [__] Micah
Republican
now Rudy Giuliani went around all these
states and pressured these election
officials we heard how he pressured
Rusty Bowers
um and and really I think and Jenna
Ellis as well because Jenna Ellis was
his right hand man in this idea and the
reason why we know she was his right
well actually maybe she was his left
hand I think left hand because when he
farted on her do you remember this he
went to Michigan to testify and make a
big hoopla with his lies and his
[__] that he couldn't say the lies
he couldn't say in federal court when
they were trying to get the court to do
something because you can't do that in
court anyways the point is
at Grandpa farty mcsharty Rudy Giuliani
otherwise known as Rudy kaluti was
sitting testifying and Jenna Ellis was
sitting to his left so she would be his
left hand man
I'm not I'm not misgendering her that's
just the phrase left-hand man I don't
know what what do you want from me
Janelle is sitting next to him and he
farts on her right
I mean it's it's audible in the [__]
microphone he farts on her so loud and
you can see her face like oh my God
and she got covered because he had coven
and he farted coven on her I don't know
if that's exactly how the science works
I don't give a [__] YouTube take this
video down if that's misinformation but
I believe
I believe that I believe that Rudy
Giuliani uh gave Jenna Ellis covet with
a fart
now
I also believe that Rudy Giuliani is is
at
at very much risk here of being
criminally persecuted down in Georgia
for his crimes of trying to get a
pressuring election officials to commit
election fraud
they were trying to get them to just
find votes anywhere or not count votes
or whatever the [__] they were trying to
get them to do and that's what this
testimony is going to show right now we
didn't see a lot of the testimony or the
grand jury conclusion
we've seen like the
you know the first part second part and
a little part in between but it was all
redacted of who were these who who the
actors were and we can only guess who
the actors were because we know who was
[__] testifying we know who was
involved theoretically
Lindsey Graham being one of them that's
why later on today when when we get to
bonehead
this idea that Mike Pence is going to
use the speech and debate clause this is
really [__] dumb that Mike Pence is
going to use the speech and a bait
clause
so he doesn't have to appear because of
a subpoena to the to the special counsel
Jack Smith in the January 6th uh uh um
Cheeto dust kangaroo coup case
that criminal case he doesn't have to
appear because of the speech and Abate
clause which has already been proven as
[__] and it's not going to stand in
court and the reason why is because
Lindsey Graham that's how he tried to
get out of his testimony in Georgia and
that [__] [__] didn't work
it ain't gonna work it ain't gonna work
it ain't gonna work Mike I mean it might
work for the fly I don't know maybe the
fly won't be able to it won't have to
testify with the subpoena did the fly
get subpoenaed do we know this can
anyone tell me did the the fly on Mike
Pence head also receive us a p I think
we should I think wow [__] I didn't
think about this listen
we should definitely get a subpoena out
Jack Smith if you're listening to my
voice we should definitely get a
subpoena out to the fly on Mike Pence's
head I bet that flying knows a hell of a
lot more than what Mike Pence does the
fly is allowed in a room with women see
that's the difference Mike Pence is not
allowed in rooms with women he can't
trust himself nor can he be trusted with
women he really can't you just can't but
the fly can be in the room so that's why
I
maybe maybe that's the relationship
between the I don't know Jesus Christ
how can we not he can't even make this
[__] up
no Lord oh lordy lordy lordy so we're
gonna find out more about the um and
maybe it's today you know Fanny will if
someone got onto me for calling her
Fannie Willis they said it's funny
Willis the reason why I call her Fanny
is because it's spelled f-a-n-i and I
don't listen to the news
I don't I don't listen to the news
on a regular basis I go read what the
news is and I'm a hillbilly so I
pronounce it how I want to pronounce it
so it's Fanny and also I'm not trying to
offend her I don't think Fanny is a bad
word I mean it can be but I don't think
Fanny's a bad word but here's the deal
again I don't listen to the news so I
don't listen to how other people say it
I don't
and and if you're not aware that I [__]
up names all the time you know that I do
not listen I don't listen to the [__]
news I don't because I [__] up names all
the time I'm horrible at reading by the
way I don't even know this you know it
happens [__] it
what other what other news do we have
today uh that's trending
now Fox News is trending of course uh we
have Rush Limbaugh again rushland ball
is trending because it's been two years
since that piece of [__] croaked and
died which you know it should be a
national holiday I don't know can we can
we petition
can we petition uh Joe Biden or congress
uh to make the death of Rush Limbaugh a
national holiday we can call it dance on
Your Grave day I don't know maybe we'll
do that maybe do that I think it's kind
of funny though that wrestling ball is
actually trending
uh every year then he's dead
or he's been dead I think that's I think
that's [__] fantastic
um
I just wonder I just wondered do they
honest near his uh gravestone do you
think they have a urinal or do you think
there's like people have to constantly
come clean up [__] [__] from people
[__] on his grave like literally
[__] on his grave or something I
don't know he's probably buried in
Missouri
do you guys know the story behind
wrestling ball
you guys know it
I I used to listen to rushland ball
every single day and it's not listen
it's not because it's not because I
I liked Rush Limbaugh Okay the reason
why I listened to Rush Limbaugh and this
is very important and I know I know it
feels like I Tony uh you've you've you
talk about him way too much listen the
reason why we have the problem that we
have with Donald Trump is because of the
mastery
that rushland ball when Institute in his
messaging and his narrative okay and it
was the timing of it that was so
important and so crucial and and yes I
mean the timing like in our timeline but
I mean the time of day the time of day
that he did his show is [__] was the
most important part about Rush what Rush
Limbaugh did now Rush Limbaugh
you know he's from Missouri he's from a
place called Cape Girardeau Missouri
it's a very rural River Town down in
Southeast Missouri and there's a there's
a really good school there it's called
SEMO Southeast Missouri
uh State and they'd call it SEMO
um it's known for a lot of different
things but it's a river town down in
Southeast Missouri On the Border
and uh he grew up as a republican his
dad was a judge his family actually were
accomplished people educated people he
was the black sheep of his family
um he couldn't handle College he dropped
out of college which I'm a two College
uh two-time College Dropout myself I
went on to be an announcer in the radio
he honestly if if you want to think
about Rush Limbaugh as as a fact of just
pure talent now he used it for evil vile
things and he pushed fascism in this
country to the to where we're at today I
don't know if that was his ultimate goal
but that's what it led up to and the
right used him as a tool to do that I
mean Rush Limbaugh to to to his own
credit uh was a self-made broadcaster
that became the the the charity case of
the Heritage Foundation is really what
happened
um he was syndicated on a ton of am AM
radio stations now
after he became uh after he was a pseudo
sort of a success at the Kansas City
Royals in radio and it's a broadcaster
he he had he had a talent for radio he
had a talent of connecting people to the
radio and then he decided to turn his
sights onto politics uh and that is
where he destroyed our country or
started to do the process of destroying
our country
um by spending his narrative and his
messaging and here's how he would do
that okay
back in the 1990s there wasn't um the
internet like we know it today there
wasn't Twitter there wasn't Instagram or
Facebook we all know this how people got
their news generally speaking was in the
morning
when they got ready for work right they
may have had the news on or on the radio
when they were cooking breakfast doing
their hair washing their ass you know
all the good things you do in the
morning to get ready for work
and then what would happen is
they would listen to the radio at work
or in the car
now Rush Limbaugh knew the news cycle
okay he knew it very well he played into
it every single day trust me I know this
I [__] listen to him
now most the time I was yelling and
screaming at can you imagine me yelling
and screaming oh my God and ranting into
the abyss
yes I would be getting into a yelling
match with rushland ball in my car
but here's the thing Rush Limbaugh did a
three-hour show every day and he started
at noon Eastern
sound familiar he started at noon
Eastern and here is why Rush Limbaugh
started at noon Eastern he let the the
new cycle of the day open okay now
everyone would hear the news stories of
the day from the prior day right A lot
of times that breaking news in the 90s
didn't get to some of these news deaths
till mid-morning late afternoon and that
news was designed for the Nightly News
rather it was your local channel that
you were watching where you watched the
weather and school closings and the
local feel good stories whatever it was
and then the Nightly News which is the
national news NBC ABC CBS and then Fox
eventually the networks okay
so Rush Limbaugh knew he knew that what
he had to do was convince people during
the day of how they should view the news
of the night because he knew what the
news was going to talk about that night
he knew the news cycle he knew what the
story the top stories were going to be
on NBC ABC and CBS and fox
those Network television Nightly News he
knew what was going to be in the
newspapers he knew what those those
National local stations like your your
your affiliate in your local town or
your local area of NBC ABC CBS their
local news coverage he knew what they
were going to be talking about
he knew this he knew what the top
stories were by the time he got to noon
Eastern
it's the most important part so for
three hours what he would do was tell
the American people what not to believe
that they're going to tell you tonight
he would Gaslight the [__] [__] out
of him he would lie to him he would make
it to where when they got to the Nightly
News and they read their newspaper
rather it was the local news the
national news or whatever they were
reading that he had already mind [__]
them he had already told him exactly how
they should view the news
he was the birth of Fox News before Fox
News
this this was a brilliant plan into
gaslighting America to get them to
listen to him for three full hours of
exactly what they were gonna listen to
that night on the local news and how
they were supposed to view it that is
the most important key to how
Republicans even still exist in power
they don't have policy they're not for
Liberty they're not for Freedom they
haven't been for a long time they've
only been for corporate profits and
their own [__] power for decades
folks
for decades this is not new I mean
they've always [__] thin veiled it
with conservatism oh we're conservatives
we're conservative Republicans no you're
not you're not [__] conservative
you're fascist you're corporatist you
want a platocracy you want an attacker
see you always have because you want to
tell people what the [__] they can and
what the [__] they can't do you want to
be up in people's [__] business
but what he did was so [__] crucial
to where we're at now
how he [__] our country
into into having the opportunity to even
consider to even consider
having someone like Donald Trump run in
a [__] primary for one of the major
parties not not even not even coming
close to the president just running
and being a serious candidate and
winning those primaries and he did and
it's because of Limbaugh it's because of
him
and and yeah you can say oh there's all
oh Tony there's also there's Ronald
Reagan then there's this and there's
that and blah blah but listen to me when
I tell you this
there's two things in politics we talk
about it all the time and if you if you
if you focus if you focus with me and
realize that there's two things only two
things when we're talking about politics
it doesn't matter what [__] issue
you're talking about guns minimum wage
health care whatever subject you are
passionate about there's only two parts
of it there's the actual policy the
governing
legislating
and administering those legislations
through the executive branch and holding
them accountable through the courts
that's called governing that's what that
is
and then there's the elections
you have to get elected in a democracy
to govern
to set or legislate policy
and that's the dirty truth of it
Rush Limbaugh didn't give two [__]
about governing he didn't give a [__]
couldn't couldn't give a [__] less and
frankly I don't give a [__]
everyone everyone on the left wants to
argue over line items and bills that
don't exist
they don't exist folks it's only an idea
and if you can't get elected you're you
just got a good idea good luck to you oh
you're doing such a bang-up job having a
great idea
if you want to make change if you
actually want to fundamentally change
how our democracy looks you want to make
it more equitable
and more and have more equality
across the board you want to make sure
that they're not stealing away your
[__] Liberty your [__] freedom and
your rights and they're not they're not
taking away other people's rights which
is a slippery [__] slope to taking
away your rights then you must fight for
your democracy and you must use your
democracy to fight for it and one of the
best weapons
one of the best weapons and most
effective weapons
to get elected
to get elected and to elect people who
are going to do that fight yes you may
not agree with every [__] point no
one agrees 100 with every [__] person
and if you agree if you meet someone
especially a politician that you agree
with them 100 on every single point your
[__] brainwashed you're you're mind
[__] you're an authoritarian you're not
you're not a liberal you are listen to
me if you find a politician that you
agree with on every single point
you are not a liberal you are not you
are not a free thinker you do not see
opportunity
I'm telling you it's not a thing go look
up what [__] liberal means
Rush Limbaugh knew all of this he knew
all of it
and that is how we've led to this
situation
is because he used his talent because he
had a massive amount of talent it's it's
a shame that rushland ball was a [__]
box it's a shame that Rush Limbaugh was
a fascist it's a shame that Rush
Limbaugh was an authoritarian he wasn't
a conservative get that out of your
[__] head it's a shame that rushland
ball
did what he did to our country
but it is it is the cold hard truth that
messaging and narrative is the only
thing that matters in politics doubt me
on this
you can oh County God damn oh my argue
with me all you [__] want argue with
me all you want
you can't get elected you can't set
policy that's just the pure [__]
facts
and you may not like that oh but but
what we need to do is we need to do this
and we need it no I again this is why I
go after t-y-t-e David packman I went
after pod Saves America this week I'll
go after anyone who does this stupid
[__]
any one on the left
and then I I got people like why are you
going to have people on the left tyt
they hold Democrats accountable they
help people on the left accountable what
the [__] do you think I'm doing when I'm
telling them their messaging sucks and
their messaging is authoritarian
oh we just need to elect someone that's
gonna wipe away everything and just with
a stroke of the PIN
don't go vote because both sides are the
same voter suppression [__] out of here
with that nonsense you're not gonna
convince me that there's no more
important thing than narrative in
messaging
it's how
you get policy makers elected yeah
here's a prime example
here's a prime example John fetterman
checked himself into the hospital
for clinical depression
what what a brave thing to do for United
States senator in this day and age to
not only do that but then to come out in
public and say it out loud Brave thing
there's a huge bad stigma for mental
illness when we all have it and that's
the reason why there's a bad stigma
because no one wants to admit that they
got some mental health problems everyone
has them we're [__] humans
we're [__] humans now it likely is
that his stroke hit the health condition
of his stroke that he had during his
campaign has caused it's an after effect
of some of this I mean Jesus Christ can
you imagine can you imagine being
trapped inside your [__] brain
because that's really the the situation
that John fetterman is in right now
the guy's intelligent he he he's very
vocal
before a stroke he can't he can't hear
he can't hear words the exact way he has
to see them and hear them at the same
time
he can't speak and he's not audible the
way he was before it must be frustrating
as [__]
I mean I can't even imagine I can't even
imagine
having these problems that he's having
where he's trapped inside his own
[__] brain
and he can't he can't get out of it
right it's like
it's like knowing what to say but you
can't say you ever done that you're like
you know the word it's on the tip of
your tongue and it bothers the [__] out
of you imagine that is your entire
existence at this point
especially when it's someone like United
States Senator he must he must feel
[__] like [__]
he must feel like [__] and I hope John
fetterman gets all the help he can
and I I hope my my hope is is that he
can he can do his entire term and run
again
I think he worked really hard having a
stroke during your campaign and coming
out and having to fight against the
Trump machine like like he did against
Dr Oz
and they did a brilliant job in that
campaign to destroy Dr Oz and to beat
him
and the United States Senate campaign in
Pennsylvania
but I can't imagine the stigma
and The Bravery that it takes but just
that story alone
you look at that story alone in the
messaging in the narrative they're going
to destroy fetterman and it's going to
work folks
it's gonna work I know I know you're
like Tony we need to fight yeah we
should fight back against it
but it's gonna work
and they're gonna seize on it the same
stupid way about these [__] spy
balloons
why my question is why are they shooting
down weather balloons I said that why
are they why stop shooting [__] out of
the sky stop stop it just because JD
Vance posted a picture on Instagram
you're only giving them what they want
win the war in messaging [__] [__] their
stupid ass [__] they won the Warren
messaging on the Spy [__] balloon
folks not enough people were here
listening to me when I was laughing off
the stupid spy balloon me and Texas Paul
talked about it
it's that complicated to understand
these things when you lose narratives
you lose political capital and when you
lose political Capital you not only lose
the ability to get elected you lose the
ability to set policy and legislate and
to administrate
because you lose the messaging
you know who knew that
you know who is damn good at it Rush
Limbaugh that's why the right funded him
that's why they're that's why the
Heritage Foundation slung money at Rush
Limbaugh like a [__] they paid
all his syndication fees
every [__] one of them all those
radio stations that you listen to them
all on
they paid all that [__]
for him
he had it eat on easy street because the
guy was talented and he was willing to
do their bidding
I'm willing to do democracy's bidding
here on the Tony Michaels podcast every
single weekday two full hours I want to
get the three because I think three is
effective and I think three is effective
at noon Eastern
every single weekday
and the reason why it's effective is
because it's worked before folks
it fundamentally changed our country it
fundamentally changed a party from a
party who who wanted to be conservative
to an outright fascist party for
neo-nazis and bashes to take over
buffoons
buffoons to take over their party we
don't have two parties in this country
that believe in democracy that is the
situation we're in
that's why it feels like we're failing
to some degree in some points in some
Avenues is because we don't have
competing ideas in democracy you either
believe in democracy or you're
Republican
and you want a king
so you decide you decide what you want
you're the audience
you're the American people you're the
voter
and we got an election to win here
that's right we've got an election to
win
in 2024 but the election that's going on
right now
is a Republican primary
and that's the election fight that we're
in and we are not we don't have a
candidate in that fight I don't know if
you know that pro-democracy people are
not going to have a candidate in the
Republican primary there is not listen
to me there is not going to be a
pro-democracy republican candidate there
is not going to be Nikki Haley and her
announcements like I want to take over
education and smash it up into little
pieces [__] your local school boards
it's basically what she said that's what
Donald Trump said the weeks weeks prior
there is not a pro-democracy candidate
on the Republican side so we don't have
a stake we do not have a voice in their
primary
you know what we can do
do you know what we can do as American
people the only we can do with the power
of our voices
we can destroy we can make them
[__] destroy themselves
we can make them fight it out and
Destroy themselves and spin our
narrative
okay this is important and I know people
like oh my God Tony you're talking crazy
you're spinning narrative there must be
lies involved you do not have to lie you
do not have to lie
to spend a narrative that's what I'm
trying to prove with this show is you do
not have to lie to spend a narrative and
to change
the structure
of the country you don't have to do it
all you have to do is be entertaining
all you have to do is look through a
lens
that the rest of the American people
look through
and our democracy a lot of people don't
follow democracy a lot of people don't
know about our democracy that's okay
that's okay
you don't need people to understand the
entirety of their civics
to understand a narrative and a message
you do not do you know why I don't feed
you full of a bunch of [__] facts and
statistics and polls and I don't put up
graphs have you ever seen me put up a
[__] graph it is very rare that I
[__] even show you a graph
I will not I will not [__] bore you
here on this show with a bunch of
[__] graphs that a bunch of liberals
think makes them look smart the [__] out
of here with that nonsense
if you need listen to me if you need a
[__] graph to make your point your
point sucks that's right your [__]
point sucks if you need a graph and
statistics and four polls and 20 other
studies to back up your point your point
is horrible listen we live in an age of
of [__] social media which you get
the attention span of about a half a
second of people and you think you're
going to convince them of an argument
when you need to show them 15 different
points of data to convince them of your
argument you are a stupid son of a [__]
if you think that's good politics that's
good narrative and that's good messaging
that's the dumbest thing I've ever heard
of in my life
that's really stupid I'm not saying the
statistics and the data and the graphs
aren't wrong I don't give a [__] is what
I'm saying
I don't give a [__] about those graphs I
don't give a [__] about the studies I
don't give a [__] about the polls
if you can't if you can't make a good
argument in a couple sentences you're
[__]
You're Gonna Lose You're Gonna Lose it's
like that's uh let me give you a couple
examples here of what I'm talking about
right so there was a um there was a
presidential race in 2020. I don't know
if you remember this no one's talking no
one's still talking about it being
stolen or anything
oh my God but there was a primary for
the Democratic candidate do you remember
this
there was a primary for the Democratic
candidate you had um oh you had uh let's
see Kamala Harris who's now the vice
president you had Joe Biden who was the
president United States now you have
Pete bootage Secretary of Education you
had Senator uh Elizabeth Warren he had
Senator Bernie Sanders uh yet Andrew
Yang that [__] idiot you had Tulsi
gabbard
do you remember this do you remember how
many of those [__] people were
standing on the stage half of them were
boneheads right and they're all trying
to figure out what the American people
wanted they're all trying to figure it
out they're trying to figure out the
people that were going to vote for them
in the primary what they wanted
and a few of them on stage thought you
know what Universal Universal Health
Care is a very important issue to
Americans let me tell you something
Universal Health Care is not an
important issue to Americans
the American people hate Universal
Health Care they hate it do you know
what they do want they don't want to go
broke because of a medical bill okay do
you see the difference they're the same
[__] thing by the way they're almost
the same thing but it's the messaging
it's the narrative Universal Health Care
Universal Pre-K Universal this Universal
that Medicare for you remember the
Medicare for all part oh God if Bernie
Sanders would have just not stopped
saying Medicare for all he might be our
president today that's the cold hard
truth Elizabeth Warren might even be the
president she wouldn't have gotten on
the Medicare for all terrain you
remember when Elizabeth Warren released
her Medicare for all playing
is she [__] lost in that moment do
you know why because the American people
think that Medicare sucks
they they think that Medicare sucks
it doesn't matter what the truth is
folks it doesn't matter and and don't
come here and oh I know what's going to
happen people are going you [__]
Medicare doesn't suck here's this study
and that study here's this poll and this
day like this and they see what you're
going to do so you're going to do the
exact thing that I'm telling you [__]
not to do
listen the American people think that
Medicare sucks I don't care what poll
what data you show me they think it
[__] sucks and the reason why is
because of Rush Limbaugh and the
Republicans for year after year after
year after year after year month after
month day after day after day in their
messaging they told the American people
that it [__] sucks and they finally
bought it
he told him a lie and they bought it
but there's nothing you can do about it
that's what they believe so what do you
do what do you do do you develop a plan
that says we want Medicare for everyone
and everyone's like whoa what the [__]
what are you talking about son Medicare
sucks do you see how that's a shitty
message do you see how Bernie Sanders
lost the primary the minute he started
saying Medicare for all every [__]
half word and and Elizabeth Warren
started saying Medicare for all Kamala
Harris started this [__] too Medicare
for all Medicare for all Medicare it's a
dumb stupid phrasing it's stupid
messaging the American people hate that
messaging and you know why I know that
because Bernie Sanders lost by big
[__] votes
that's how I know I don't need any other
[__] data point I don't need you to
tell me this or that and it had nothing
to do with the actual plan not the
actual plan I'm not against Medicare for
all I'm not against it not against it
I'm against the messaging because the
messaging sucks it's horrible just like
the build back better bill they were
trying to make an education Bill and
infrastructure bill because they thought
that was good messaging
[__] that [__]
listen Medicare for all sucks that's
shitty messaging people don't want to go
broke because of a medical bill
people do not Americans people in
America do not want to go broke because
of a medical bill that is good messaging
yeah it takes a little longer to say it
it's a little chunky and it's you know
it's hard to carry around who gives a
[__]
if you walk up to someone
I swear to God just do this
walk up to someone anyone just Rando in
the grocery store say hey let me ask you
a question
do you like Medicare for all no [__]
that [__] that's Universal Health Care
that's garbage okay so you don't want to
go broke because of a medical bill right
that's what you want yes absolutely I
would not ever want to go broke because
of a medical bill
it's the same thing it's the same thing
get them on our side do you see how that
works do you know do you know how we
have and I'm going long here on the a
block I apologize
but this is important in messaging
because Rush Limbaugh is trending and I
feel like this is an important topic to
talk about with people because it was so
[__] long we've listened to these
stupid [__] liberal Elites tell us
how to win elections and they lose them
they [__] lose them
you doubt me [__] doubt me [__] and
doubt me because they were all behind
Bernie Sanders and Medicare for all and
they [__] lost to Uncle Joe and you
know how they lost Uncle Joe Jim Clyburn
of South Carolina went out before that
primary and said hey go vote for Joe you
can trust him that's what he said
that's what he said he didn't say go
vote for Joe he's going to give you the
greatest Health Care Universal plan of
all time you'll never you'll never not
have a paycheck
he's gonna be the most socialist
president ever in the history of ever
ever he didn't say that he just said Jim
Clyburn came to the microphone and said
folks the candidate to pick is Joe Biden
he cares about the American people he
will fight for the American people
and that is the candidate you should
choose
and they did
overwhelmingly they did in South
Carolina you remember Iowa oh [__] Joe
Biden was broke there was no way he was
even gonna make it to South Carolina guy
didn't have any [__] money blah blah
blah yeah you know what in Iowa I
predicted to my family and friends I
said Joe Biden's gonna win
Joe Biden's gonna win this race no he
won't no he won't he's [__] broke
he's gonna win
and I knew one one reason and one reason
only why Joe Biden was gonna win
he wasn't playing into the [__]
messaging
he was being Uncle Joe from Scranton
Pennsylvania
he's just the average average
dude walking around who happened to
become a United States Senator
who Delaware was happy to have him
represent them in the United States
Senate for decades
and then he became the vice president
United States because the dude knew a
shitload about foreign policy and Barack
Obama didn't and Barack Obama needed an
old white dude to be quite Frank to make
[__] Americans feel warm and fuzzy
doubt me you can say whatever you want
about that but that's the [__] truth
and Joe Biden proved to be a very
effective vice president
not only that he beat the [__] pants
off the Cheeto dust q and honor Donald
Trump by eight million [__] boats and
the reason why is because this trunk
country trusts that some [__] they may
not like him they may think God he's old
but they [__] trust him because he's
one of us
he's one of us
he's not some [__] liberal Elite he's
not some [__] some MIT Harvard
educated ivy league no he's one of us
do you know how Joe Biden when he first
sworn in as a United States Senator do
you know where he's sworn at do you have
any idea in a [__] Hospital
standing over the bed of his of his sons
who were in a car accident where his
daughter and his wife were [__]
killed in a car accident
he could have backed away at that point
he could have went away but he didn't
he stayed because it was important
and he never gave up he never gave up
and he still isn't giving up
that's why that's why we're gonna look
back on this time and realize
that Jill Biden may not be the best
president of all time he may not be the
best order
but he's one of the most effective
politicians of our time
and it shows it shows and I hope John
fetterman does the same exact thing
because when you get into a hard time in
life when you get into a hard time in
life that's not the end that's the
beginning in most cases
but it's the end of rushland ball of the
right because I am the self-proclaimed
now
people are tweeting about it uh Linda is
tweeting about it oh boy she's probably
in the chat too everyone's tweeting
about the rush limb all the left spread
the word
spread the word out there I'm not scared
of it you're not going to offend me not
one bit everyone we got a few Clips to
show you from today uh from the shitless
Roundup before we go to the bonehead of
the week I gotta give you some news Gabe
Sanchez can't join us very long now he's
only joining us during bonehead so it's
going to be short this week so I I doubt
we're going to go over two hours
I know everyone looks forward to two and
a half three hours on Friday but we're
probably gonna be right at two hours
he's joining us for bone of the week but
stick around I'm gonna go through the
shitless Roundup right after this
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
Glenda Linda Linda Linda
oh boy oh boy I'm gonna be in trouble I
think over this
I didn't I had no idea
I really didn't I didn't know Russian
balls I didn't have it on my calendar to
this day that he broke
um I didn't have that on my calendar but
Linda Linda certainly did she said some
people are saying Tony Michaels is
rushing the ball the left is it about
time post-cued to get aggressive about
democracy and being on the right side of
History goddamn right God damn right if
you don't know what I'm talking about
tune
the [__] Wednesdays at noon oh thank
you Linda Oh everyone spread the word
spread the word
and wait till the righties find out
about this see you know the left's gonna
be really mad if they if they figure
this out uh if and they're going to be
really pissed off
like they're like oh that's disgusting
you say things like Democrats and
gerrymander yeah they should you [__]
ain't right in the blue States they
should gerrymander the [__] out of those
districts [__] them [__] them [__] em
[__] em [__] em gerrymander the [__] out
of it we should we should make sure that
we're running huge campaigns to suppress
the the Trump vote
huge campaigns for them to self-suppress
I don't mean like legislate laws to
suppress them I mean running campaigns
to suppress their vote they do it
anyways they don't trust voting anymore
I don't know if you noticed that but
they [__] hate they hate electronic
voting Dominion they're stealing the
election
2036 mules or some dumb [__] I don't
know
I got all kinds of [__] fake ass
movies and [__] that they spend they
do [__] this Reawakening campaign
where they run around on all kinds of
[__] churches
all over the [__] country with Mike
Flynn and Eric Trump talking about
stolen Alexis and [__] [__] that [__]
yeah it is stolen it is stolen we'll
steal it every time for you there's no
use for you to vote don't even try to
vote because we're going to steal the
election from you
why why
don't don't you understand that who
gives a [__] if who gives a goddamn [__]
if we use messaging to make them
self-suppress their vote they did it to
democrats for years they do it to
Democrats in Texas I don't know if you
noticed this
but Georgia went blue
in the presidential election in 2020 and
it re-elected a Democrat
as their United States senator in
Warnock it went blue think about this
for a second
that would mean that would mean that
Georgia always to some extent had enough
Democratic votes
hmm I bet Texas has enough Democratic
votes but they're just not going to the
polls and the reason why is because
they're like ah well we're going to lose
anyways
think about that if that's the mindset
that's always been that's why Democrats
always
we're kind of horrible at winning
elections in some states
uh we're gonna lose anyway there's no
reason to go
self-suppression
[__] that let's do it today let's let's
use the situation that they put
themselves into by believing election
lies and election fraud lies let's use
it to our advantage to win
how do you think how do you think we are
ever going to make sure that we get
Voting Rights passed in this country
if we don't abolish the filibuster
in the Senate and if we don't have the
majority in the house you think
Republicans are going to pass voting
reform
that's going to help the American people
actually vote
get the [__] out of here with that [__]
the only reason why they have the house
in the first place is because of
gerrymandering
and the gerrymandering that we let them
do we by not gerrymandering our blue
states that we have control over and
just let letting them willy-nilly do all
the red States you're like oh Tony
that's that's terrible that you would
suggest that is it really that terrible
for democracy that I would suggest that
is it
is it is it
the reason why we have five Republican
senators from the state of New York is
because Democrats don't gerrymander the
[__] out of that state gerrymander the
ever loving [__] out of New York [__]
them [__] them
they do it in Alabama they do it
Mississippi they do it in Louisiana they
do it in Texas they do it in Georgia
they do it in Florida get the [__] out
of here if you think that our democracy
is is not at risk because we won't fight
for it
every single one of their gerrymandered
every single one of their gerrymander
districts went through the courts and
won
did Mark Elias fend off a lot of
gerrymandering absolutely did Democrats
win a lot of battles
in court to fend off a lot of their
gerrymandering absolutely and I don't
think we should stop doing that either
and here's the thing here's the thing
that you're going to be like oh my God
this is so disgusting oh my God are you
listening to what you're saying Tony yes
I am listening I'm saying it out loud
thought a lot about it
we're going to have to go into red
States and go make a case in front of a
court
of why Republicans can't gerrymander the
way they're they're gerrymandering and
then we're gonna have to go on Blue
States and gerrymander the same way
they're gerrymandering yeah we're gonna
have to do that so what we do is we just
rely on Mark Elias he's a really good
[__] attorney by the way he knows he
he knows voter suppression very [__]
well he knows all these laws really good
he knows them well like there's no one
there's no one but Democrats that know
these laws and what you can and can't
get away with better than anyone else in
the country
because they're always fighting this
[__]
like we know it better than anyone why
the [__] aren't we doing it
and you say yeah but you know are we
gonna lower to their
to their level
are we going to lower to their level
I don't know do you want your democracy
do you want it
I don't know I mean I mean I'm asking
you
you're you're you're the real voice out
there I only again I've said this before
I only have one microphone you got
thousands
I speak I think it's about fifteen
twenty thousand people across platforms
come and watch this show or listen to
this show every single day and so number
15 to 20 day to day it's kind of you
know between that number
foreign
microphone you guys got 15
000 20 000 microphones and it's gonna
get better and better and better and
better and more and more and more
microphones
this show is just gonna grow
I I know I know this show is uh on a
path to be probably one of the most
hated political commentary shows in the
country
good
good I'm gonna piss off [__]
Republicans like a son of a [__]
they're gonna hate my [__] guts you
know who else is gonna hate my guts
people on the left
who want to clutch their [__] pearls
who want to act like we we can't do
those things to save democracy Tony
Jesus Christ what we would look like
Hypocrites if we won elections that way
and then when we won those elections
then what we could do is make sure that
there wasn't gerrymandering oh my God we
could legislate gerrymandering out of
existence that would be horrible Tony
do you see what I'm saying here you know
that I'm saying don't just [__] just
take power to take power that's not what
I'm saying I'm saying I'm saying
stop being such a [__] ass [__] win
elections and then change it to where
they can't steal the [__]
to where no one can steal an election
how the [__] do you think work how the
[__] do you think we're gonna get Voting
Rights passed how the [__] do you think
we're going to codify Roe B Wade in the
federal legislator how do you think
we're gonna do that
do you think we're gonna do that by
letting them run rough shot all over our
[__] democracy and not us not
defending it [__] that [__]
quit clutching them goddamn pearls get
over it get over it and realize that
it's at stake here
it's at stake we're not in a hot War
we're not in a hot Civil War we're in a
war Civil War of information folks
and they're gonna win if we don't fight
that war of information
they're gonna win because they're not
gonna stop they won't [__] stop
they're not gonna stop
they're in it for the wrong reasons
that's why they won't stop it's greed
it's power
and let me tell you something it's worth
fighting for
it's worth it
democracy is tough
liberalism is strength if you think if
you think that liberalism is weak then
you're an authoritarian
and you're a dumbass
frankly if you think liberalism is weak
you're a stupid [__]
and I say this over and over and over
again because it works
do you know why I repeat the same things
over and over and over and over and it
works
I listen to it work
the motherfucker's dead but they still
[__] play clips of him
saying the same [__] over and over again
why do you think Donald Trump
it still has any kind of political
capital in this country
he understands that tenement of
messaging
messaging and narrative or everything
it's everything
and you can use the truth
you can use what is real and reality
to frame up narrative and messaging and
you can do it in the way that they do it
like the the bombast and the outrage I
do it every day
I do it here every day every day you
come here to to get a cathartic release
and an entertaining release from the
garbage that is going on in our country
where the Republican party is trying to
turn us into an autocracy
by taking away rights from women by
taking away rights from the lgbtq
community by taking away rights for
people of color
by absolutely defending their white
privilege
to the death sometimes
we saw that yesterday as the Buffalo
shooter was was oh I went and I went in
that grocery store to kill black people
and I know now that I was mind [__] by
the internet and it convinced me to do
it and I'm so sorry and I regret it and
I can't take it back no you can't
so what are you gonna do what are you
gonna do you're gonna you're gonna sit
in a corner and clutch your pearls
and cry about how your democracy is
being Stripped Away from you and your
children your grandchildren
are you going to throw those pearls and
say [__] that [__]
let's defend this democracy let's make
sure let's make sure that we my
grandchildren and my children aren't
[__] victims of gerrymandering
that their freedoms and their Liberties
aren't put on The Chopping Block because
the minority ideology gets to control
governments in this country [__] that
[__]
[__] that [__] [__] them well enough of
this garbage enough of this [__]
footing around and and treating these
people
like this we have to go at them and go
at them hard okay let's go to the
shitless round
I just rant rant and rant all day long I
could do this for five hours I promise
you I promise you oh by the way
uh before I go the shitless Roundup I
want to thank all the uh patreon members
over there on patreon yesterday I
explained how I get paid this is my job
and how I get paid so if you missed that
maybe you should be you should go if you
want to know I'm going to be very
transparent I'm going to talk about this
more because I want to be transparent
with you guys about how I get paid and
how I make a living doing this because
this is my job
this is my job now I made it that way
um it's it hasn't been an easy thing
financially but
uh because I don't just get paid by
George Soros no one [__] George Soros
does not cut me a check I wish he did
honestly it would be an easier way to do
this
it really would if he just [__]
George listen if you just want to send
me
you know I have so much every month I'll
do this for now until Kingdom Come
but I don't get a Soros check I get paid
on your support your support you the
audience that's how I get paid
and one of just one of those ways just
one of those ways is a new is a new way
I make extra content over on patreon so
if you want to be a member over on
patreon and I want to tell all the
people over on patreon thank you for
being members this weekend I'm going to
do this Shout Out video for all the
people I owe shout outs to so I'll do a
shout out video in the next week
uh when I release the shout out video on
social media I'll give you a shout out
on the show so you get two you get one
in the video and then one on the show so
I'll be looking for that but go check
out patreon it is one of the ways that I
get paid and how I get paid is I give
you extra content I give you early
access to content just go over take a
look at the the um the tears and it's
just one of the ways that I get paid so
I can stay in front of this microphone
yell and scream
and hold these Republicans accountable
just one way so let's go to the [__]
list to Roundup start the countdown
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
for about 30 minutes trying to time it
correctly and he has limited time this
week but we are going to get bonehead of
the weekend you know in the second hour
of the Tony Michaels podcast every
single Friday you vote you decide and we
break down your vote on bonehead of the
week
speaking of [__] bonehead and they
didn't make it on the bone-in so I want
to show you this clip this is [__]
something else Republican accountability
had this video from Mar-A-Lago
what in the [__] is this [__] I said
just out there invent reality and [__]
these people are just making up [__]
they continue just to make [__] up
it's
it's actually funny it's [__] bunny
you can't help but laugh at this how
pathetic they are what a bunch of
[__] losers can you imagine can you
imagine if the entirety of the
Philadelphia Eagles football team was
like yeah I mean we went to the Super
Bowl and we gave it a good try and uh we
won and stuff we won by a lot actually
uh don't believe what the media tells
you don't believe what the score told
you don't believe what the officials
told you don't believe what the NFL
tells you we won and we won by a lot and
that's that's just uh that's just how
we're gonna view it at this point we're
the Super Bowl champions even though
we're not actually the Super Bowl
champions because
um we're a bunch of dumbasses that is
literally what these people are doing
and then people would [__] laugh at
the Philadelphia even the Philadelphia
Eagle fans to some extent they might
play along with this for a while but
after a while like all right cut that
[__] out that's [__] stupid you sound
like a bunch of goddamn [__] ass
[__]
saying that you won when you didn't win
that's what they are this is of course
you can see the Cheeto dust queuing on
her here in front of a microphone down
at Mar-A-Lago good God do you think they
throw these parties just so he can get
up in front of a [__] microphone to
feel good
you think this is like his therapy
session like he gets depressed and he
shits a few diapers and like you know
what we should do we should throw a
party for the for the boss guy tonight
and we should really throw a party for
him and we changed his diaper so he's
clean so uh we got his makeup done and
we got him all dressed up in Trump drag
um you know we did his hair put his
makeup on uh put his high heels on got
his girdle belt on so he looks thin
because he's a fat [__] now what we
should do is throw him a party set up a
microphone let him talk and do it for
about three hours say the same old [__]
but and everyone will stand there and do
a golf clap making him think he's an
important it should be really good for
his mental health whoosh this guy's
office rocker listen to this [__] and
now I I want to give you an idea Kerry
lake has been going to Mar-A-Lago a lot
she's been going to Mar-A-Lago for a lot
a lot a lot of time at Mar-A-Lago and
she's in the crowd tonight and we'll
talk about Carrie Lake and why Nikki
Haley isn't going to be vice president
on the other side listen to this Kerry
Lake who went through
[Applause]
you had a great race in Arizona she won
she won by a lot
um Carrie lake is at Mar-A-Lago there
sunny Boy
she's not uh at the Capitol in Arizona
she's not the governor
um someone else is I think it's her
opponent who beat her in the election
the worst part is is that Kerry Lake
Carrie lake has lost another Court
battle in her effort to act like she won
the election when she didn't really
um which is only worse for her now my
belief is is that Carey lake is trying
to get on Donald Trump's ticket to be
the vice president I think she will too
I think he's going to pick Carrie Lake
honestly I know he's going to be the
nominee I know that for sure no way he's
not going to be in the nominee doubt me
on this the only thing standing in
Donald Trump's way is a cardiac arrest
or choking on a [__] Big Mac or
something right or chicken bone whatever
you know sloppy he's eating down there
but Carrie lake is my best guess for his
Presidential nominee and that's why
Nikki Haley the idea that she's running
for president to be the vice president
is really [__] dumb really [__]
stupid Nikki Haley she wanted to be the
vice president she would be down there
smacking elbows with Carrie Lake trying
to get her out of Mar-A-Lago like Nikki
Haley would be at Mar-A-Lago every
single one of the times they had these
shitty diapers diaper therapy sessions
where they set up a [__] Podium and
make him think he's important I'm
serious is this all staged look at this
they have a [__] DJ over here look at
this guy DJ there's I mean and they set
up a Podium like there's no reason and
look how pathetic this is oh it's gonna
load God damn it my [__] internet
son of a [__]
oh let me see if I can get it I want to
show you the crowd is why I want to show
you the screenshot of the crowd is what
I want to show you there it is there it
is so here's the screenshot of the crowd
I mean dozens maybe tens of people right
and probably some of this is staff and
other people are probably actually like
in events that are like away from
whatever the [__] this little
again dirty diapers therapy session for
him this is they probably go into like
like the wedding hall are the are the
other Halls where they're having like
group events like hey can we steal about
20 people
uh grandpa really wants to come out and
speak to some people in front of a
microphone would you loan us 12 14
people to come on down and take a listen
to his nonsense for I don't know a
couple hours that way we make him feel
better
mm-hmm
[__] real everything with this guy's
[__] bake none of it's it's all
[__] fraud get the [__] out of here
you can't convince me that those people
are there like yeah I went there to
listen to him
okay yeah and Carrie Lake seems to be
spending an awful lot of time
um at mar-a-longo
it's kind of suspicious
I don't know Nikki Haley I think you
should drop out of the race and go down
and start kissing his ass like Carrie
lake is that's probably gonna get you on
the vice presidential part of the ticket
more than him destroying you in a
Republican primary hmm okay one other
video I want to show you and then we'll
go to
um uh speaking of
people who are gov this woman is
actually a governor can you blame this
[__] she is actually a governor
this is crazy [__] Nikki Haley was a
governor
Carrie Lake wanted to be a governor
she isn't because she's crazy and this
[__] weirdo
is a governor she's a [__] governor
of a state South Dakota but
let's listen to
Governor gnome here let's listen I
suspected Greta and this is just me in
speculation I may be a bit cynical but I
assumed they waited to shoot you may be
a bit cynical just a bit you think
this is the same stupid [__]
that wanted to put Trump's head on Mount
Rushmore remember this oh yeah she's
really excited about [__] rock raping
uh Native Native Heritage and and and
[__] sacred grounds sacred
tribal grounds of indigenous people down
the Chinese Bible she really wanted to
uh and rock rape it by putting Trump's
head on route right get the [__] out of
here
we already did enough we already did
Enough by [__] Plastering slave
owners
faces all over that place anyways let's
continue with her nonsense she's going
to talk about the Spy balloon and I'm
sure she's got a great take on it let's
listen found the Chinese spy balloon
over the ocean so that if something
couldn't be recovered that they didn't
want us to know that it was an easy
excuse that it was somewhere in the
ocean and they couldn't find it okay
this person also is probably another
candidate for vice president but she
really [__] boring do you know that's
how boring she is even on Newsmax she's
on Greta's the ancestryan's show and
she's really boring I mean he's like
he's like super boomerang and stuff she
just the Chinese bad blue shot down over
there she's [__] boring as [__]
Carrie lake is way more interesting than
this person I mean at least Gary Layton
understands how to use a filter
look let's keep going she says something
about she's starting about spy balloon
but she talks about the other stuff that
was shot out of the sky which we're
finding out today and she's a bonehead
that if there was some piece of
information on that balloon or something
that was detrimental that they didn't
want the American public to know that
there would be a good reason to why it
couldn't be recovered these last three
balloons now they have shot them down
over land when you shoot things down
there is debris we should have been
there immediately to recover it and done
an analysis and known exactly what these
objects are the fact that they tell us
they don't know what they are is
unacceptable and we're not dummies see
okay well they did tell us what they are
they're [__] weather balloons oh my
God I think someone said that me I said
their [__] weather balloons
they're weather balloons they were they
were weather balloons
so Chrissy gnome thinks that when you
shoot down a weather balloon
in the Yukon Territory I don't know if
you know what the Yukon is I mean you
live in South Dakota so you're way
closer to the Yukon than what I am so I
mean
my theory of closeness I guess I don't
know you should know more about the
Yukon but here's the thing is the Yukon
is a very remote place now by land it
takes a minute to get there okay it
takes a little bit to get there by air
that's why we fly planes from like New
York to LA it doesn't take near as long
see here Chrissy listen
if you hop in a car in New York City
you're saying if you hop in a car in New
York City and one of your partners
hops in a plane and you drive
to Los Angeles
but they fly they're gonna get there a
hell of a lot quicker than you are okay
so just think of it that way Chrissy is
that when they go to shoot down of
innocent harmless weather balloon
because you people are [__] terrified
of these things and you're going to
start firing guns in the air it's not
shot down
uh the plane gets to the weather balloon
to shoot it down a hell lot quicker than
what they get to it by land to recover
it do you get it do you understand how
this
Jesus Christ it's it's do I really have
to explain this to these people what a
[__] idiot and then the Q and on
conspiracy theory where she's like oh
they shot it down over the water that
way that way the government could
retrieve it and the government could
cover up what was in it that's why they
shot it down over the water as if the
government wasn't going to recover it
rather they shot it down on the water
they shot it down over land this is
really stupid stuff she's like hey you
should go recover this stuff so we know
what was in it but when you recover it
you're gonna lie to us
stupid [__]
stupid [__] bonehead speaking of that
speaking of boneheads we have bonehead
of the week
so everyone stick around we're gonna be
right back with bonehead of the week
right after this break
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
I've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever I try it never
sticks so when Babel made a MAG Edition
I knew I had to give it a try Babel Maga
Edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacists the first lesson
began with learning simple phrases and
soon I was putting those words and
phrases into a conversation each lesson
takes about 10 to 15 minutes to complete
and they're all really different which
keeps things interesting the app is
really smart it actually keeps track of
the words that I'm struggling with I
chose Babel mag Edition because it's
created by smart white people like me
and now I can't wait to explore meet new
friends and use my new Mega skills with
my in-laws all lives matter
[Music]
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the Tony Michaels
podcast you have reached the segment of
bonehead of the week every single Friday
in the second hour this uh Gabe Sanchez
this bonehead is a little different
because people in their recent weeks
it's like it's the same boneheads every
time everything but we decided to and we
could have done the same boneheads
but early on we were like these are the
options right they're they're solid
go-to options why I mean why can't we go
with those options but I want to tell
the audience you're limited on time
today so bonehead is going to be really
rapid and very fast here
um bonehead rapid fire right rapid fire
bonehead today so be prepared but boy do
we have some rapid fire candidates that
moving on
the former vice president United States
Mike Pence I'm gonna take his battle to
the Supreme Court for the for for his
subpoena issue by Jack Smith the special
counsel we have a bow tie tuckhams
Carlson uh from White Privilege tonight
over there on fake news
um he's he said some bone-handed [__]
about Chelsea Handler and I think we
have an alpha cook also
um in that cat same category for that
and then Nikki Haley of course Nikki
Haley announced this week Gabe Sanchez
that she would be losing the Republican
presidential primary against
in the race only for it to be stepped up
right well I mean this is this is how it
goes so let's let's do this should we
start with uh Tucker Carlson here
because I believe I believe the tape
from
um his show where he's talking about
Chelsea Handler and I'm not sure who the
wish.com
Trump Jr is that he's talking to uh in
this clip but this is actually uh let me
see if I can share my screen properly uh
we're in such a hurry here to get the
bonehead in since Gabe is short on time
here we go there we go now we're good to
go so like we're cooking
well you know what let's uh we didn't
even do the music yeah I was I didn't
know if you were gonna well you know it
happens let's just get into it because I
know I don't want to lose time here so
here is uh tuckums and this is actually
Chelsea Handler's video I don't know
that we'll watch the whole thing but
let's look at what why Tucker Carlson is
on the bonehead of the week A Day in the
Life of a childless woman the point is
to make you feel good about being an
aging deeply unlikable woman who never
had kids feminists like Chelsea Handler
they've been lied to by their society
forever that you could be a girl boss
and you can do anything a man can do
who is this guy by the way I don't know
who this [__] is then he look
like like he's trying to be Don Jr I
mean he's doing the hand he's not doing
the hand I mean his face he's got the
beard I mean he almost looks the same
way when I when I do an impression
you know I get I get the beard makeup
the white the white flecks which could
be his aging it could be a little powder
doesn't really matter but it does so
wait wait you think in his impersonation
of Donald Trump Jr here he's possibly
doing blow on the set of Tucker Carlson
just to make it authentic allegedly okay
well you know many week many people many
people are saying many Joe Biden Jimmy
would
the funny part about that is I actually
don't know who Jesse Kelly is but that
name sounds like he's a man oh yeah
doesn't it sound like he's an [__]
title it sounds privileged it sounds
like he was the guy who wasn't always in
the uh the Boating clubs on the East
Coast but he always tried like he was
rubbing the deck and really you know why
he probably wasn't you know why he
probably wasn't he was getting his ass
kicked by a bunch of girls that's
probably what why he's so [__] upset
and he's talking about girl bosses
because they used to boss his ass around
let's let's continue listening to this
idiot when who's ever seen a woman about
back up a vehicle knows that's not true
what what
I'm sorry
backup Vehicles look listen I I've seen
a lot of people not know how to parallel
park and I've met a lot of dudes that
absolutely cannot parallel park I've
driven a lot of big vehicles in my life
I haven't driven like a semi tractor
trailer or anything so I wouldn't I
would struggle with that probably but
I've driven a lot of really long really
big vehicles and I
I can maneuver them around but it has
nothing to do with the genitalia that's
in my pants it's just the experience
that I have doing it and really honestly
I think it's hilarious that these [__]
these these [__] Cuts think that
women can't back up Vehicles well I like
that that that the only thing that
disqualifies a woman to be like oh well
we shouldn't take her seriously she's
not a girl boss because of driving like
not how she's not even driving just
backing up a vehicle just like all right
I line up I go mirror to mirror I go 45
degrees I come in look but again that is
the same argument that all Republicans
have it's when you don't actually have
data and an argument
to come back with and actually debate
you just go against a personal attack
you mean they're full of [__] magazine
you mean they're full of [__] hundred
percent so what's Maga 101 let's watch
Chelsea's response here
if if it will load oh my god of course
of course
maybe she's like well she could be
bionic boss lady
um of course you know there there you go
there you have it the Tony Michaels
podcast having the troubles
we'll do it live we'll do it live okay I
think
yeah I think I have I can make it I
think I can make it work now and then
and then we'll move on to the next
bonehead uh but I want to get a little
bit of Chelsea's response and the reason
why is because uh if you look up here in
the corner there was another there was
another [__] uh that we're gonna
talk about in this Chelsea Handler Saga
but let's see what Chelsea has to say
about some of these these these Cuts
hairline Society to discuss a comedy
video I filmed about not wanting kids
wow why would I even need my own
children when I get to hear these cry
babies all the time I mean I can't
believe that bearded version of Tucker
Carlson thinks I would take a half a
bottle of Xanax I take way more than
that you silly goose but I don't want to
debate whether or not I'm a girl boss
although I did just look at my bank
account I think that's pretty girl boss
okay so she goes on here with the jokes
but the moral of the story here is that
Chelsea Handler was guest hosting at The
Daily Show they've been having guest
house since Trevor Noah left she did a
comedy video about how she doesn't have
children and she chose that right she
made that choice because I don't know we
live in a country with liberty and
freedom and where women have bodily
autonomy and they can choose right they
they have children or not you know it's
kind of a funny thing uh Liberty and
freedom little too crazy on the Liberty
freedom for Antonio well it is you're
getting a little too Progressive right
it does piss
let's piss off um very very very
shitheaded white men when women have the
ability to make a choice right and
Chelsea Handler is pointing it out there
and we'll get to a little more of the
Chelsea uh Handler story when we get to
the alpha cook of the week but I want to
go back here
um to someone who kind of got kind of
got
cut this week before announced
um oh yeah it's kind of it's it really
is it really is kind of weird
um do we have that is it the not the
Patriot is that the one yeah that's the
one
um I have the clip here uh
of uh how she got cucked
um I mean it's it's been ongoing here
for Nikki Haley now she announced that
she's gonna lose the presidential
nomination for the Republican party this
week
um and before she announced when they
announced that they were going to
announce Donald Trump started to just
drag her and he basically destroyed any
chance she had to get her campaign I
mean he's trying to burn everyone who
ever was in his corner and is now
debating the idea or considering the
idea of you know stabbing him in the
back right well his biggest Challenger
is Ron desantos the governor of Florida
not to be confused but George Santos
Rhonda said to be confused with George
Santos this is Rhonda Santos
um as I am going to call him from now on
um but meatball meatball is probably his
biggest threat meatball Ron but Nikki
Haley poses a little bit of a threat
because I I really don't understand it
she's she's kind of an idiot I mean and
kinda is really uh I'm being nice I'm
being nice yeah I'm being nice
um and the reason why she's kind of an
idiot is because she's a coward and this
is a video that Donald Trump actually
played when she announced that she was
going to announce that she would run to
lose the nomination let's listen he
still has a lot of popularity if he runs
again until 2024 will you support him
yes
yes if he decides that he's going to run
would that preclude any sort of run that
you would possibly make yourself I would
not run it
oh she's a line sack of [__] that makes
me think she's Republican or something
it sounds like there's something I don't
know ingrained in the DNA
May that says uh if there's ever a lie
you can always just believe and know
I guess I guess I'm moving on in my
brain that's fine
another liar I I mean you said are in
there
three times in a mirror she will appear
oh God Jesus Christ do it at your you
know your own just
expression well and I'm not gonna even
go there Petty Eddie Petty Eddie yeah
now this clip she's done a lot of
bone-headed [__] in the last few weeks
she thought an elementary school in
Illinois got five gazillion dollars and
I think it is gazillion I think it is
yeah started with a billion but she
moved to a Gazoo I mean the woke element
the official count is literally made out
of kale leaves right that's that is true
and they have litter boxes all the way
they don't even have lockers yeah they
just have litter boxes down the hallway
for the kids to [__] in and because
they're eating so much kale I mean this
is of course it's a fiber right when you
get a lot of fiber you need a lot of
litter boxes for these self-identified
lib cats not libtards
um but she said something boneheaded the
other day and actually I didn't even
catch it till yesterday she compared oh
my God
at the the plane that was taken down uh
by the passengers in 911 so that it
would not be flown into any more
buildings in Pennsylvania
and somehow conflated it with the
Chinese spy balloons and now what we
know this morning is weather balloons
these other things are like oh my God
what are what are these things that the
vitamin oh my they were weather balloons
just what I said several when they first
started shooting you saying I'm like
they're probably [__] weather
balloons one of them I was reading I
don't know if this was confirmed so this
is just me speculating on just a
headline
was uh was from a hobby group that was
shot down on the Midwest I mean poor
timing not not time when when everyone's
on high alert and they're and radar is
just like hey anything sensitive that
hits this threshold we should go after
I mean can you imagine a hobby group
spending all of their money to be like
great we're going to run
a good time who knows how much time they
spend on this [__] they just shoot it
up and then they just watch it just a
[__] missile just just destroy that
thing and I I watched um another
bonehead uh the the governor of oh one
of the Dakota what's her name Christy
[__] no no no no no no mind no I'm
not smart the one who helped her
daughter get the the real estate and all
that I don't know she's a [__] she's
a republican so what else are you gonna
do but Christy gnome was on some Trader
TV News Network and she was saying like
something about these balloons like why
didn't they get them right like one of
them was in the Yukon you bonehead she
was like why weren't they there when
they came down to the ground like
you know how fast it is to put a [__]
fighter jet in the in the sky and take
down some it doesn't take very long yeah
this was in the have you seen Top Gun
they watch way too many movies don't get
him any [__] ideas that's like this
clip here let's listen
yeah
that we're given on this we're pathetic
absolutely pathetic they told us it was
too risky oh it was too risky to shoot
down the Chinese Bible and do you know
what a bunch of [__] that is
you know that really Christians speech
you yeah I mean just
just for everyone back ground on this
this thing was the size of three school
buses not the mini ones the full-size
ones the ones they went to school or
took field trips on three school buses
and that was the length that it was now
I don't know if anyone remembers I don't
know a class called physics but you've
got gravity right science
the amount of of weight that is Excel
when you when you you know negative 9.8
meters squared is the action you know
the the speed of gravity here if you
want to do the full equation you you and
yours I mean honestly that's like one of
the things that I will never forget from
science class but if you were if you can
just imagine three
three three length of school buses
coming down over a state a populated
area you had JD Vance point which I
think was the same day the train
derailment happened I don't know if
that's correct but you had him pointing
a gun you had Don Jr saying shut it down
you had Donald Trump saying shoot it
down all of these Republicans went crazy
the next day they shot it down yeah like
the next [__] day after they assessed
they scrambled uh they collected data on
it they waited till it was over a
non-populated area in South Carolina
right and then shot it down and then
collected it and now they're analyzing
it well you know what's crazy is these
weather balloons these little weather
balloons that these hobbyists have put
up right what they're gonna
dude what they're gonna be saying is
down innocent people's weather balloons
you sons of [__] like that's gonna
you you shot down a weather balloon with
a missile what are you crazy like that's
gonna be their [__] and they're gonna be
they're gonna be trying to pass bills to
to make sure that Joe Biden can't shoot
anything out of this game that's
literally what you would think that the
group that goes would love to shoot down
balloons in the sky well they would
until Joe Biden does it and then it's
not cool anymore but let's let's listen
to how uncool it is her comparison to 9
11 here it's it's kind of [__] gross
they said it's three school buses three
school buses why that's what it was well
do you guys remember on 911
crashed in Pennsylvania oh God a
jetliner remember that don't kill
anybody on the ground
okay okay
this is the same [__] that was
like did did the plane actually crash
into the Pentagon or was it a missile
this is the person that we're supposed
to be listening now this is disgusting
and gross but in all seriousness are you
surprised that this that this [__]
troglodyte
says this kind of [__] I'm not surprised
after after the speaker vote she went on
to onto the news networks and did this
like whole PR press tour to be like I'm
not crazy right right crazy right I used
to believe in Jewish space lasers I only
kind of do now right I mean look a lot
of the conspiracies that Marjorie Taylor
green if not all of them deal with
anti-Semitism so just keep that in mind
I mean 911 we've got uh the vaccine
passport and mask mandate she likened
that to the gold stars that Jewish
people wore during the Holocaust which
is just disgusting
then she talks about Jewish space laser
she talks about George Soro she talks
about this you know Malik the devil
Satan about
how there's this Democratic uh cannibal
uh pedophile cabal or she calls it cable
yeah well I mean right he's crazy well I
mean we know that I mean and and we know
that when she's like yeah skill Illinois
what elementary school 20 gazillion
billion thousand four hundred and sixty
five dollars it was it was a bad deal it
was a bad deal what do you got to say
about that drag queen and I I that like
literally that's that's what they're
saying
and you're like no you what I don't know
what he I don't know what you're talking
about I don't know what you're talking
about speaking of don't know what you're
talking about Matt Walsh definitely does
not know what he's talking about never
he has no [__] clue he wouldn't he
wouldn't know anything listen
he wouldn't know a woman
if she sat on his face okay because he's
like what is a woman
what is a woman I don't know I have no
idea what a woman is he had to go all
around the country and all around the
world and figure out what a [__]
woman is right I mean a woman to him is
a 15 year old girl well I mean he does
like to marry he does like to marry them
young he likes to marry them young so
they'll stay married to him forever yeah
like you know prisoners or captives yeah
it's weird it's almost he's got a rapey
it's kind of rabies
uh speaking of um being pathetic here's
what he says about the chance
video we we saw Chelsea's response to
him
um but he was one of the ones that
chimed in he was not the only one it
seemed to be like this fragile white
male pussy-ass [__] type thing
almost it's almost like Chelsea and The
Daily Show writers team we're like hey
we've got an idea that I'll probably get
a lot of attention it'll trigger a lot
of these white guys and then they made
the video and it did just that right and
they just watched them fall into it she
said nothing about them though
specifically she didn't Target them she
didn't like quote tweet them she just
said it and they're like oh you [__]
[__] because here's his here's his
here's his here's his little whiny
little [__] Tweet now this is the
first one there were several he went on
and on and on for days I even at one
point I said [__] you're still talking
about Chelsea come on man
Let It Go man she had you she already
she already handled this okay so here's
what he says nothing more pathetic than
the the coping done by a childless woman
pushing 50. like what does he want her
to do she's now in her 50s she wants she
wants her to have eight kids or some
[__] what the [__] is he talking about I
mean she's [__] look like she said in
the video you know she looked at her
bank account she was like that's a
pretty girl boss right she's had
multiple Netflix specials Netflix shows
she had her own talk show New York Times
bestsellers book
books she's had other tours that she's
done I mean she even dated 50 cents you
know right not to say bring up 50. but
the 50 number right there she dated 50
Cent okay that is that's pretty girl
boss I'm gonna Matt Walsh doesn't have a
chance in hell to date nowhere [__] 50
cent no way no [__] way no [__]
way he goes she he goes on the wine she
could have had kids like what who the
[__] cares and still be doing basically
whatever she wants with her life today
what do you get why do you people care
so [__] much about what other mind
your own [__] business Matt mind your
own [__] business and then he says
this this is this is [__] hilarious
kids aren't toddlers forever like dude
yeah but they're your children forever
forever and ever ever even even when
you're dead they're still your kids like
what are you talking about as if as if
the only stage of having children and
considering having children is the
toddler stage right but also makes it
seem like the only purpose for a woman
is to have children right that's what
these men are saying they're saying the
only the only the only role that you
have that's right making a sandwich
Barefoot in the kitchen and bearing kids
you're a brood man you're a bird mirror
get get the pre get to being pregnant
um so he goes on again to wine and [__]
here he says she could have had her
quote freedom and a family
why do you why why why do you are so
concerned about her Freedom yet you
don't think she has the freedom to not
have a [__] family this is the same
nonsense where they're like oh we have
the rat to own guns yeah but you don't
have the right to impede my right not to
have them right exactly want to have
them in my life and not and be safe from
them okay that's because you know right
for me not for me like you know you want
you want to push people away and say no
no I get these things and you get none
of those things I mean it's almost it's
almost like they want to have the
freedom to force their beliefs on us it
almost seems that way it all I mean
we're getting yeah that's exactly pretty
close and then
of course he has to add in his one dig
he thinks a great joke like this he
really think this is a joke right like
this is fun this is Republican this is
mag I think right here if I insult and
attack someone on a personal level it's
one totally verifiably true and also
it's a funny joke
instead she'll die alone is what he says
ha funny but that's also assuming that
it's like okay she'll die alone meaning
that she'll die alone without kids like
what if she has a great partner like
who's she dating I don't know but also
not my business right the fact is it's
these people lives
everything from the genitalia to the
gender to what bathroom to what pants
you wear to a clothes you wear to a
church you worship to this and this and
that they care so so much about what's
happening in someone else's life they
are the walking embodiment of a you know
a nosy Nancy right like they can't help
get their [__] nose in in the [__]
dirt in the gossip they love it they
can't go without it even though hey I
don't know maybe you should focus on
your own family Matt or your own
children you know I feel very very bad
for the children that he hasn't had or
whatever those four [__] kids oh my
God because my response to him was cope
[__] ass [__]
like what why why are you so concerned
about what Chelsea Handler does and I
wanna I wanna thank another woman for
that one Chrissy Teigen for entering
that one into absolutely oh my God just
to the the so the society like lexicon
of ways that we can call out anyone from
Matt Walsh Ben Shapiro Tucker Carlson
Elon Musk Donald Trump you name it [__]
ass [__] like though like a rainbow
over the perfect way to represent yes
absolutely and you know I will never
refer to them as snowflakes again I
wanna I I actually you know what right
now I want to sincerely apologize to all
moglodytes out there that I referred to
you as snowflakes and not
the correct term [__] ass [__]
speaking of [__] ass [__] our winner
this week
um the vice president former vice
president United States Mike Pence and
the fly on his head have been subpoenaed
uh I believe that the fly is not going
to fight The subpoena but but the the
winner of the week the bone of the week
Mike Pence is going to fight this
subpoena from Jack Smith my guess is is
because he doesn't want to be
responsible for putting the nail in the
Trump coffin here with Jack Smith
because he knows he [__] knows he
[__] knows and and to give everyone
an idea my belief is is that the fact
that Mark Meadows and Mike Pence have
been some
peanut this week means that Jax is
signaling that he's targeting trunks
specifically for crimes and Trump knows
what crimes those are based on who he
subpoenaed but the fact of the matter is
is that Mike Pence and Mark Meadows are
not targets
in his investigation I don't believe
that I don't believe that their targets
because they're being subpoenaed but
Mike Pence vows to take this to the
Supreme Court which this is going to die
in flying Flames we'll explain right
after the clip here let's listen back on
January 6 president Trump was wrong
to overturn the election
but I would say in this very moment you
tried I'm so wrong
to establish a precedent
where
a legislative official could be called
into a court by an executive branch that
whoa wait a second
I I clearly you know from my ninth grade
civics course I clearly remember which
is probably more than a lot of
Republican lawmakers have well that's
probably true
um but I clearly remember gave such as
from my from my ninth grade civics
course is that the vice
the United States is not I I mean I can
look but I don't believe that he is
um in the legislative branch it almost
feels like he's in the executive branch
Am I Wrong Am I yeah there's like a
whole cabinet uh of people you know
so like a box that they sit in yeah or
like you know you put them on a shelf
and they're like you've got you know
everyone from I see you know
Transportation I didn't know if it's
like a cupboard or if it was like a
wardrobe I wouldn't know it's kind of
like an open kind of model you know they
just want to make sure you want to make
sure maybe within the and on on the
label it says executive branch shelf
okay well I just want to make sure maybe
we should send that memo to Mike Pence
here like get get the end of this
because this is important
that runs against literally hundreds of
years
and that's why we're prepared to take
this fight into the court good luck and
if needs to be taken to the Supreme
Court of the United States
he's the [__] bonehead because
[Music]
I mean look I'm no lawyer right but uh
whenever I hear comedy me either can you
believe it me either whenever whenever I
hear common law I instantly think oh
common law marriage right seven eight
years
you own a certain amount of property you
lived together I never heard anyone try
to say well I was technically for that
period of time on that day part of the
legislative body and it's been I held
the hammer yeah I held that I was sure
practically I was Thor practically I
held the hammer I mean he never he
didn't even hold the hammer until later
that night after he had to run into like
a loading dock and then on a phone call
with with other people try to be like
hey are we sending the national right
when Nancy Pelosi was trying to get him
to do his [__] job so here's here's
what I'll tell you
feet what might Pence is actually doing
and we're kind of kidding around here
yeah yeah but what what Mike Pence is
actually doing is he's trying to use the
speech and debate clause where there is
separations of power and that's not
gonna work and the reason why is because
there was crime involved and there is no
Clause that prevents the Department of
Justice for I don't know indicting for
what's that word called crime yes yes
and and we don't have to go back
hundreds of years yeah we don't have to
go back tens of years just like months
on their speech and debate clubs because
there was a grand jury in Georgia I
don't know if you know this the report
uh actually a few pages of it was
released just recently about the crimes
it was heavily redacted for the people
who were involved because a shitload of
people seem to be going to be indicted
over this not just for perjury but also
crimes that they committed during that
entire process of trying to steal the
election
um and it wasn't immigrants they were
all Republicans kind of suspicious but
here's what I'll tell you is that
Lindsey Graham do you know Lady Lady G
do you know this guy he's a United
States Senator you know him okay that
guy tried to use the speech and Abate
Clause to not testify and not and and to
not appear with for a subpoena in that
Georgia grand jury do you know what
happened to his case
Court do you know what happened to him
I'm gonna I'm gonna guess there was a
big L
in front of the in in front of like what
happened right you know you know what's
even funnier about that is that Lindsey
Graham is actually a legislator he's not
part of the executive branch which Mike
Pence was when he was the vice president
so Lindsey Graham actually had a better
case and still [__] lost he's like I
was actually a senator right and uh yeah
I should have like if you
it's just not a good
you can try all you want right you can
kick in you can scream I mean again if I
have to remind everyone that they
literally built Gallows and screamed out
hang Mike Pence and Mike Pence is like
look
uh Donald Trump did some bad stuff that
day and uh yes people threatened to kill
me and my family play but what I won't
do is I won't testify against Trump
because there's something that will be
real that won't won't be so good for
Trump and possibly and possibly me I
don't know you know it might piss off a
lot of Michael knights in this country
and that's what we're here for on
bonehead the week let's give former
device president Mike Pence and his fly
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
oh Mike since you are the bonehead of
the week every single Friday here on the
Tony Michaels podcast you come for
bonehead of the week and a clip on my
dispatch Network do not forget to
subscribe to the Tony Michaels podcast
come over to the YouTube channel where
you can vote for bonehead of the week
every single week on the community tab
you know what there's another way to
vote too Gabe Sanchez you just go to
Twitter follow at Tony Michaels pod and
you can vote for bonehead of the week
there also do us a huge favor here at
the Tony Michaels podcast we're not just
on on Fridays in the second hour We're
on on five days a week Monday through
Friday and you can download every single
episode in audio form on Apple Spotify
leave us your favorite review there
while you subscribe
no Mike Pence Mike Mike Pence so Mike
Pence you stupid stupid little boy
no no everyone stick around I'll be
right back Gabe's gotta gotta head out
I'll be right back for more more
announcements on our live broadcast this
has been bonehead of the week
[Music]
[Applause]
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker Convoy
there's Tammy by the time we reach DC
White was 50 strong in number some
patriots ran out of gas along the way
we got plenty of Slam jams skull
near run out Natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
Circle the city again
dear Bob I'm fixing to send you some
more of them Doritos you like the red
bag not the lived love and blue one
in your absence I discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and I
even seen my cousin Brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
ears Tammy
[__] em we're back to the Tony Michaels
podcast
back to the show
[Music]
I want everybody to thank Gabe same kids
popping in for bone end of the week
bonehead of the week
favorite segment he didn't have a lot of
time
so we worked it in we worked it in for
you for bone end of the week now to make
sure that you got your Gabe fix
everyone's like oh where's Gabe where's
Gabe where's game they're always they're
always trying to um
I I tell you what Gabe Sanchez
um has been on the show for over a year
now
he's been the co-host and executive
producer he works really hard here at
the show but he also works really hard
on his what was that
um he has a separate piece of content
outside the show
originally we were going to make it a
segment of the show but as we were
developing it
and forming it it became very clear that
it was in and of its own piece of
content in and of itself so it was its
own piece of content and it's come a
long way and um I'm super excited to see
where what was that goose for Gabe
Sanchez even though he he can't be here
for the rest of the show today I I do I
do want to say that
um I'm I'm very proud of the things that
he's going to accomplish here on out
with the what was that so if you would
do me a favor and do Gabe a favor
because we have people were confused the
other day about our patreons we me and
Gabe have separate patreons my patreon
is for my additional content and Gabe's
patreon is for his what was that so when
you when you go support me and my
patreon it supports me and you get that
extra content and then when you go
support Gabe and his patreon that's for
the what was that
so and be aware of that I want the
audience to be clear on that is that his
is for what was that in particular and
the reason why is because he spends so
much time on that piece and I think he's
releasing one today I believe that's
what he said earlier he texts me I think
he's going to be releasing one today
um so go check out
um Gabe's patreon the module put it in
the chat below but it's also in the
description below just go to patreon.com
I am Gabe Sanchez and give Gabe some
support over there on page just check it
out just check out what he's got going
on there maybe you'll join as a member
and support that content I would like I
honestly I think that's such a good
piece of content that he could compete
with The Daily Show I really do I think
that is such a good piece of content
he's got his monologue down he's got the
the timing down he does such a great job
with it visually and the graphics and
the jokes I mean does such a great job
with it
um but to get it to five days a week and
make it a bigger piece than what it is
yeah money things cost money they're not
they're not free so we can only do them
so long for free so uh what was that is
a great piece of content that Gabe
Sanchez works really hard on he writes
them he produces them he records them he
edits them all by him Lonesome that is
just him doing that
um so I I I I'm very very very excited
to see where what was that can go
um and and it's it's up to you the
audience to consume it to watch it to
support him in that effort and I hope
that you do because I know you support
him here on the show so I hope you
support him outside the show uh with
what was that with his own show because
it is it is it's become its own show
again we were going to do it as a
segment
and we were developing it as a segment
but it became very clear very quickly
that it was not just a segment that it
was its own show in and of itself so
thank you for supporting me but also
thank you for supporting Gabe I love
that you guys hate it when Gabe doesn't
make it on the show because you love him
so much so and I know he he wanted to be
here longer today but we had to squeeze
in bonehead of the week what would
bonehead of the week be without Gabe
Sanchez what the [__] what would it be
without Gabe Sanchez with just me and it
would be a little bone-headed to do
bonehead of the week without him so and
also uh yeah so uh the the chat people
are putting in um the moderators are
putting in the links in the chat but all
of the links are down below like in our
YouTube description you can find Gabe
Sanchez's linktree you can find his
patreon you can find the store which I
want to bring that up while I'm talking
here uh over the weekend I'll be putting
out more merchandise with the Surfs Up
logo on it the Surf's Up art Surfs Up
[__] t-shirts and coffee mugs
I'm gonna put up more merch I think I'm
gonna do a sticker a hoodie I'll do some
other stuff this weekend
so if you're still waiting on that
merchandise be watching my social media
accounts whether it's Twitter or
Facebook and I'll put up some
announcements when I post those also you
can you can go to my patreon page and
I'll be posting it there too so if you
want to see like when merch drops early
or when my social media videos are gonna
drop early it's what I've been doing
over on patreon and I do a a weekend
rant I do it on Sundays I usually Post
in the afternoon it's not a set time it
just it's on patreon I just do a weekend
little rant I usually try to pick
something that um that I don't think is
gonna make it to the news cycle next
week so what I try to do is find
something that's only going to be
relevant in the weekend because they're
gonna [__] do something stupid and
there's gonna be some other bonehead by
the time Monday comes around you know
what I mean so something will happen
tonight or tomorrow and I'll have to
talk about it on Sunday or I won't get
to talk about it at all because we only
get two [__] hours on this show
break down the stupidity and it's just
not enough with the stupidity that we
have with the Republican party in this
country it's just not enough
it's not enough and we want to go to
three hours that's what our patreons are
for
patreons help support us because this is
our job this is how we make money and
again uh yesterday I was I was trying to
be very transparent and I want to be
more transparent with the audience and
talk to you guys more about how we are
actually making money doing what we're
doing here now I think that's important
especially when you see like the right
wing do you remember several like a
month ago was it a month several weeks
ago when Stephen Crowder it was
they talked about how he was going to
get like 30 million dollars or some [__]
to go have a show on The Daily wires
like 30 million bucks
Jesus Christ that's why they say that we
get paid by Soros this is why they say
we get paid by Soros
because we don't get paid by anybody we
don't get paid by anybody
you're our support you the audience are
our support like when you come watch our
clip for instance like if you go watch
our clip on Midas Touch
um bonehead of the week we just did bone
of the week we put a clip of it on minus
touch
and if you go watch it over there and
you watch an ad and you see an ad we get
part of that
so like YouTube gives us ad dollars The
Advertiser whoever whoever buys that ad
on that video
we get paid on Twitch if you on Twitch
you can um
you can you can uh uh excuse me log into
twitch with your Amazon Prime account
and and you get one free subscription to
do that and you can choose the Tony
Michaels podcast as your subscription
and then you won't see any ads
um and and we get a few dollars and it's
a couple bucks I think two or three
dollars for the subscription that you
get for free so it doesn't cost you
anything if you have an Amazon Prime
account and you are not logged in on
Twitch and give us the um the actual
subscription do that because it's it
doesn't cost you any extra because
you're just logging in with your Prime
account and we get a few bucks for you
having a Prime account and I think you
have to constantly do that like like a
couple times a couple times
so um
so again
the other the other way that we get paid
is from the ad dollars there and the ad
dollars on Twitch right the other way
that we get paid is when you go buy
merch so you go to
store.dtonymichaels.com we get a portion
so whatever you spend already use a
discount code or not uh there's a
discount code on patreon if you're on a
certain level there's also discount
codes that pop up on the website in and
of itself they're random
um I don't control when they pop up but
I have it to where there is a discount
code that pops up randomly but um but if
you go to store.donymichaels.com any
merge You by there whether it's the
Surf's Up [__] or the Ron
DeSantis can go [__] himself or the the
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty or any of
the new designs that we have coming we
have [__] ass [__] 45 designs coming
so go to store.d Tony michaels.com that
is a way that we get paid we get paid
that way because I get a little portion
uh for the show for that so so there
there's there's that
um so we we get paid in these little
ways and but I wanted to be clear that
our patreons are separate because
someone was asking that the other day
Gabe's patreon is for the what was that
specifically he's trying to use patreon
and your support to help him
do more of those and do them faster
because he just he needs more time and
time is money so if he can free up his
time because he has support he can make
more of those and he wants to get to I
think he really wants to do like five a
week and I think he wants to broaden it
to where it's a whole show where that's
the what you see now is like a monologue
and then maybe he does some interviews
maybe he has some other segments that he
puts in there so be like a whole show
every day
um so so do me a favor go check it out
over there I mean I think I think his
lowest here is five dollars the same on
mine on patreon so check out our
patreons just check them out if you want
to give us some support fantastic if you
don't have the money for monetary
support that's great too come watch
every single day share this show share
it with your friends your family
tell everyone that you have now you're
now listening to the rushland ball of
the left I'm dead serious uh there's
some people already on that on Twitter
like oh that's not the that's not as
badass as you think it is and then
there's someone uh let me see here it is
uh let's see
yeah let's see here
you wanna you wanna smash some liberals
here's here's uh one person says it's
like being known as Alex Jones of
rational Discord so I said
so I said oh I I misspelled it because I
was going fast people are now are not
only saying excuse me people are not
only saying I'm the wrestling ball of
the left but also the Alex Jones
irrational Discord I'll take it I'll
take it listen Whatever Gets attention I
don't give a [__]
care whatever gets your attention to
come here and listen to the show again
folks I told you this yesterday
there's two things with national
narrative and media that is important
that the right understands that the left
fundamentally does not understand they
just don't get it they don't understand
it go listen to NPR for a half second
and you'll realize that the left does
not understand how to entertain people
when they're talking about politics
listen you have to [__] be
entertaining people have to want to
listen to you people have to desire to
figure out what the hell it is that
you're saying and then they'll listen to
what you're saying that's the most
important thing that's the most
important thing and that's what I'm here
to do every single weekday Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific is to help you with that message
and that narrative narrative out there
in the political body so we can win some
elections so come every single weekday
on YouTube make sure to subscribe don't
forget to subscribe here on YouTube
also follow us on Twitter at Tony
Michaels pod download every single
episode on Apple Spotify and Google
don't forget to follow us on Facebook at
the Tony Michaels you can find us on the
up by our YouTube channel too just go to
the upwire.com the upwire.com and go
follow links to the YouTube channel it's
a great creators Network there's a lot
of creators over there go check it out
and then you can follow us on Twitch
like I said log in with your Amazon
Prime account
now if you have one you get a free
subscription you can give it to us and
it helps out the show free way if you're
already got a Prime account free way to
support the show on Twitch thank you
everyone everyone have a great weekend
we'll see on patreon this weekend and if
you're not if you're not a member Patron
don't worry I'll be back here on Monday
same time same place Surf's Up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow toning
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[__] them [__] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon